next to a landmark ruling on what's been
called the biggest tax
heist ever germany's top criminal court
has outlawed the controversial trading
practice
known as comx the scheme involved
traders claiming rebates on taxes
that had never been paid costing
taxpayers billions of euros
germany's federal court of justice has
made it clear
those who get refunds for taxes they
never paid are liable to prosecution
like many other financial jugglers two
british bankers made a lot of money with
these comex activities
they say they were simply exploiting a
tax loophole which was not necessarily
illegal
now they've lost their case and been
sentenced to probation
one of them has been ordered to pay back
the 14 million euros profit he made
the comex scam ran for many years here's
how it worked
on the day the dividends were paid on
shares investors sold the shares on to
each other during the course of the day
only one of the parties paid capital
gains tax on the dividend and was thus
eligible for a rebate
those who paid no tax before selling
them on applied for refunds nonetheless
the authorities had no way of tracking
the transactions and paid out to anyone
who claimed
and could prove ownership on that day
the schemes that were being run had
neither to do with legal structures
no with simply exploiting a legal
loophole you know
as the legal situation was unambiguous
there was no loophole here
on the contrary it was a bold grab into
the till
into which all taxpayers normally pay
which by the way
is no different from ordinary sales tax
fraud
analysts expect many more comex
prosecutions to follow
across the entire financial sector a
whole range of renowned banks and
investors were involved in the tax theft
which left the authorities simply
overwhelmed for many years
all right let's get some analysis now
with my colleague stephen bearsley from
dw
business so good to have you here with
us on this story how
did this go on for so long with nobody
noticing probably one of the biggest
reasons is that because there isn't a
traditional victim in the sense that
there's no individual or group of
individuals who are really hard hit and
go crying to the police
in this case the victim was the state
itself the state treasury
as you can imagine that's big monolithic
it doesn't really know sometimes what's
coming in what's coming out
so it's hard to imagine a situation
which it raises an alarm suddenly
the second is that this was so
institutionalized financial advisors
lawyers involved
high-powered banks as we just heard this
was seen as a legal loophole for so long
that i think many
alarm bells didn't go off when people
saw this in the end it was really a 30
year old desk clerk
and a tax center in bonn who raised the
red flag and said this doesn't look
right why are there so many tax rebates
coming from one pension fund
in the u.s to the german central bank
and so that led to a number of other
things
2016 the ball really started rolling
they started talking to some of the
bankers and investors who are really at
the center of this
is this a scheme that was only used in
germany or also elsewhere lately this is
used everywhere i mean this was 55
billion euros
is believed to have been lost by
treasuries across europe 12 different
countries
the majority of it 32 billion in uh
germany now imagine the wire card
scanner one of the biggest scandals in
german history
four billion euro loss to creditors
through that company's fraud this is
tremendous eight times that so it's a
very very big deal
um and this would involve institutional
investors from around the world
these are massive sums i mean i can't
even wrap my head around it
how are they going to get it back that's
been the question at this point because
there is a statute of limitations with
tax matters what this court decision
essentially does is say
this is a criminal matter now and that
means there's a longer statute of
limitations we just heard
thousands of cases underway but those
are complex and costly so how much are
they going to get back
oh boy all right stephen burlesque from
dw news thank you so much greatly
appreciate it
you